all right so we're up to today's we're
gonna be shooting a snowboarding video
uh we're basically gonna start off at
the top of the mountain to shoot some
dialogue and the guy's gonna spend the
rest of his time on the mountain running
from explosions because he's on an
exploding volcano uh bear mountain has
been kind enough to give us access to
the runs uh give us a rider and a guy
who's actually gonna help us shoot it as
well and it's gonna be pretty awesome so
you know we're big uh we're actually
we're big fans of ssx we played it a ton
back in the ps2 days and so it's kind of
been a little bit of an inspiration for
us to go out here and shoot just an
over-the-top snowboarding video we are
uh prepping our cameras for a awesome
day of shooting we've got two red epics
we have the awesome fs100 that you're
gonna be using and we have a
bag full of gopros
guys let's go to the top of the mountain
yeah
[Music]
so i got this like
15 pound
60 000 rig right here i'm gonna be
getting out the chair lift here on my
skis and i hope i don't fall
what's up we made it i survived
okay kirk what's up what's a good trick
to start this off with
i think we'll uh lace it up with a
backside 360.
cool what's the backside 360.
so
that's good we all nailed it it was
perfect dan nailed it on the drive-in i
got on the camera we nailed it on the
other camera and kirk did a flip like
he's been doing every time
what's up guys here's your camera back
no um i just gotta run and piss real
quick cool
dude
ready to see some sweet jumps no all
right
[Music]
you